[Музика]
хто всіх і ласкаво просимо назад на
урок англійської мови сьогодні ми поговоримо
про вивчення мови за допомогою технологій
для початку давайте подивимося на
запитання, чи є у вас багато програм,
які робили програми  які програми ви використовуєте найчастіше,
якщо ви берете телефон або
планшет, які програми ви можете знайти
там багато з них комплекти і останній з них чи
є у вас програми для вивчення іноземних
мов, які вони насправді під час
наших попередніх уроків, про які ми вже
говорили  деякі з них, і сьогодні
ми додамо більше, а друга частина нашого
уроку буде присвячена пасивному залогу
ready go, тому перша частина уроку
– це урок читання, чи подобається вам читати,
давайте перевіримо для початку, подивіться
на малюнок, що таке  Ім'я цього хлопця,
де ви знайшли відповідь у
завданні, тому перегляньте завдання, як
його звати, правильно ви Емре, і що
ви дізналися про нього із завдань, які він
хоче, щоб програма допомагала йому добре вивчати
англійську мову  йому потрібно знайти відповідну
програму, дані
Mabini dadada так, з якою метою
вивчати англійську. Набір і завдання для
читання читайте про Емре та зверніть увагу на
ключову підкреслену інформацію добре давайте
прочитаємо
Емре часто вважає мовні програми легкими
та хоче трохи потренуватися  він
хотів би покращити свої навички читання та
аудіювання, і він має намір використати
це під час своєї короткої подорожі до школи та зі
школи,
скільки частин інформації ви можете
побачити підкреслено, порахуйте їх, скільки отримайте
три частини інформації, які
найкращі перші, які Емре знаходить мовні програми
легкий і хоче трохи складної практики,
насправді це його перша вимога
до нового додатка, і мова йде про
належний рівень складності; добре,
яка друга вимога, що йому потрібно, щоб
покращити навички читання та аудіювання
, чи потрібно покращувати граматичний
словниковий запас
нічого з цього виграти та добре слухати,
що є третьою вимогою, яку
слід швидко виконати під час його короткої
подорожі
ось три вимоги, а
тест полягає в тому, щоб прочитати три тексти та
знайти правильний додаток, який є правильним, той,
який відповідає всім трьом вимогам,
ми збираємося виконати відповідне
завдання для читання, тому знайдіть  додаток, який ідеально
відповідає любовним вимогам, давайте
подивимося на першу,
щоб програма була слово в слово сила полягає в тому,
щоб вивчати слова, допомагають приємні
ігри, в які ви можете грати самостійно або онлайн
проти інших користувачів, які забезпечують хороше співвідношення
ціни та якості  тривати лише кілька
хвилин, тому це ідеально підходить для автобуса,
поверніть праворуч вниз, там не цікаво, так
що тут про цю програму, чи йдеться
про граматику чи лексику,
що ви можете побачити тут, це про
вивчення слів добре, що ще тут надано
про програму ось кілька ігор,
тож це конкурентне право Prada, а
третя – лише кілька хвилин, щоб
завершити ігри, маючи друковані матеріали
, хороша ідея підкреслити ключову інформацію,
чому це потрібно зробити.  Не заощадимо ваш час
пізніше, давайте перейдемо до другого
тексту, тому програма англійська сцена Англійська
сцена дорога, але
рецензентам часто ставлять п’ять зірок,
дизайн привабливий з відео професійної якості
та чудовими заняттями
, які потрібні  час використовувати цю програму
належним чином, і вона найбільше підходить для
учнів вищого рівня, вони
підкреслюють інформацію про ціну, це може бути
важливо, тут інше стосується
дизайну, напишіть ще одну ідею, що йдеться
про відео, тому це для відпрацювання
навичок аудіювання шум  і вправи
до них, і правильний – це
для учнів вищого рівня, тому це означає,
що тут ви можете знайти вправи з
вищим рівнем складності, прочитайте
третій опис, щоб новини попросили
прочитати його, зосередившись на ключовій
інформації  яку інформацію
ви хотіли б підкреслити, яка
справді важлива, чи знайшли ви це,
давайте перевіримо, допомагає зрозуміти історії
з онлайн-газет і подкастів  тож
газети, які призначені для приємного читання, і
подкасти, які призначені для прослуховування, давайте
перейдемо до іншої важливої
ормації, ви можете встановити часові обмеження, що
б ви могли контролювати тривалість вр
жаюча, а набір питань ча
то досить складний, ви ще па
’ятаєте  і підвищити вимоги до
програми, ось вони, вони мають бути з
належним рівнем виклику або складності,
який із трьох може забезпечити йому
інший, це має покращити
навички читання та аудіювання, хм, не так багато чотирьох,
тут йшлося про слухання, а
тут обидва читають  і прослуховування, і
останній має бути придатним для використання в
коротких подорожах добре, що ми можемо побачити,
але останній випуск новин ідеально підходить.
Давайте підсумуємо всі етапи, які
ми пройшли під час виконання цього завдання, що
ми зробили спочатку, ми проаналізували завдання  ми
точно знаємо, перш ніж читати, на чому ми
повинні зосередитися, отримати тоді ми
підкреслили ключову інформацію
під час читання кожного тексту, чому це
потрібно, тому що в останній момент  У період, коли
ми дійсно шукали відповідну
програму, це заощадило наш час, нам не довелося
читати весь текст від самого початку
до кінця, ми просто звернемо увагу
на підкреслені частини і порівняємо
їх з вимогами, і вуаля,
ми  я зумів виконати завдання, звучить добре
правильно, давайте рухатися далі, практикуючи його.
Цього разу ви збираєтеся прочитати про
трьох підлітків та їхні вимоги
до програм для вивчення мови, давайте
подивимося на завдання, тому з ще
трьома підлітками, які хочуть  програми, які
допоможуть їм у вивченні англійської мови, знайдіть
три ключові речі про кожну людину та
те, що вони хочуть від програми, скільки
речей знайти там один два три,
безумовно, тому в кожному тексті про кожного
підлітка знайдіть ці три
важливі відомості готовими до використання.
предмети в школі, але вважає, що
їй потрібна додаткова допомога в англійській мові, їй
набридло виконувати традиційну лексику
та граматичні вправи, і вона шукає
щось інше, що можна швидко виконати,
тому що  ви помітили три важливі
відомості про Анну та її
вимоги до програми. Ви
помітили,
давайте перевіримо, тому, перш за все, їй
подобаються всі предмети, тому вона може бути
зацікавлена у вивченні англійської мови чи чо
ось іншого, можливо, про історичну бі
логію, але англійською та  роблячи це,
вона скористається найкращим з обох світів, чи
пам’ятаєте ви цю фразу з нашого
попереднього уроку,
ще одну інформацію, їй потрібна
додаткова допомога англійською мовою, тож це означає, що, можливо,
вона не вчиться просунутою так,
я б добре її налаштував, а третій
їй набридло виконувати традиційну
лексику та граматичні вправи, тому їй
потрібно щось захоплююче, молодь швидко
завершити, щоб зайнятися виконанням гарних завдань,
є ще й читати про Луїзу
вони люблять дивитися фільми та телевізійні
комедійні шоу англійською, але хотіли б
краще їх розуміти, як він очікує
додатків, щоб добре виглядати і готовий
витратити багато на правильний, що
важливо тут, говорить, що він хоче
краще розуміти  які фільми та телевізійні
комедійні шоу гарно, що ще програма
має виглядати добре, це про дизайн правильний
привабливий дизайн добре, а третій
він готовий витратити багато витрачати багато
на правильний каже, що гроші не
для нього, давайте перейдемо до  третя, якщо
любить розважальні мовні програми, які дозволяють
їй змагатися, зокрема, вона
зацікавлена в розвитку своїх навичок словникового запасу, во
а не проти відремонтувати, заплатити за
ось, якщо це вартує ціни, во
а не проти болю добре, що ми можемо пі
креслити тут, вона хоче  грати в ігри
так, щоб виконувати дії, щоб взяти участь
у змаганнях, знайте, що
ще вона хоче покращити ваш
словниковий запас, потрібно знати більше
слів,
добре, і останнє, за яке вона готова заплатити,
але
тепер має три частини важливої
ормації  про кожного учня, кожного
студента та вимоги до програми,
давайте перейдемо до читання про програми
читайте про три програми для вивчення
англійської мови знайти відповідний додаток для кожної
людини, як ми збираємося робити  це завдання,
безумовно, прочитавши та виклавши ключову
інформацію правильно, давайте почнемо
часто практикувати 3000 чоловіків
із паролями 300. Ця програма призначена для
студентів рівня та включає дуже
поширений діапазон типів діяльності, вона також
включає кілька ігор, у які ви можете
грати самостійно або з  інші користувачі
щомісяця додають нові запитання про те, що ви
тут на лінії,
і давайте перейдемо до іншого тексту.
Дизайн біт англійської мови яскравий і
привабливий,
однак додаток переважно являє собою серію
посилань на короткі, але іноді досить
просунуті відеоролики з документальних фільмів
.  Кліпи не завантажуються разом із додатком,
тому вам потрібне швидке підключення до Інтернету,
щоб переглядати їх добре.
Знайдіть ключову інформацію, відому
в свіжому й незвичайному додатку, який викладає
англійську мову за такими темами, як наука та
історія.
учням, яким важче досягати
прогресу, це безкоштовно, тому іноді вам
доведеться дивитися відеорекламу, щоб
продовжити користуватися  це зробити те саме знайти
ключову інформацію, давайте повернемося до
попередньої частини про учнів, швидко
оновіть, кому з них потрібен який додаток, який
вона любить з усіх предметів, але їй потрібно
трохи розважитися, виконуючи гарні завдання, тобто
про фільми, комедійні шоу з
видами діяльності та дизайном  важливо правильно,
вона хоче змагатися, і їй це потрібно, щоб
покращити свій словниковий запас, добре
перевірити ваші здогадки, готові, давайте
поглянемо, тому першою була Анна
, схоже, Сімас підходить для неї,
чому, тому що це викладає англійську
через історію науки та інші  шкільні
предмети правильно, що ще для
учнів, яким важче досягати
успіху, і їй потрібна додаткова допомога в
англійській мові, один цикл свіжий і
незвичайний, а Unwin o – це слово про виконання
традиційних видів діяльності ідеально підходить,
безумовно, давайте перейдемо до іншого
учня, тому  будь ласка, пам'ятайте, що йому потрібно
щось з хорошим дизайном, а
ось дизайн яскравий і привабливий,
ось просунуті відеокліпи, і ми знаємо, що він
любить дивитися  ing movies good Я погоджуюсь, давайте
перейдемо до третього учня, тому це
яловичина, у ньому є багато найуживаніших слів,
і ми знаємо, що Єва хоче потренувати
свої словникові навички, це включає
кілька ігор, у які ви можете грати
самостійно або з іншими користувачами та Єва Єва
хоче змагатися, тож, схоже, ми
знайшли програму опору
для кожного учня. Отримати налаштування, давайте подумаємо
, поглянемо на питання, як
ups можуть допомогти вам у вивченні мов,
безсумнівно, питання в тому, як
які навички володіти всією мовою  області можна
покращити за допомогою програм, спробуйте відповісти на це
запитання добре, які з цих шести програм, які
ми ознайомили з ними,
ви б хотіли використовувати, і залежить від того, що ви
хочете покращити правильно, а останню з яких
програм ми вам допоможемо  під час наших
уроків уже використовували онлайн-школу, і
насправді сьогодні я збираюся поділитися з
вами ще одним найкращим додатком, чи
знаєте ви, який це вікторина, ваша англійська,
спочатку перегляньте інформацію про
цю програму, це весело, новий спосіб
Практикуйте покращуйте та перевіряйте свою англійську
, змагаючись із учнями з
усього світу, чи
можете ви уявити, щоб вивчити англійську, бабуся,
відкривайте нові англійські слова та випробовуйте
себе у справді глобальному середовищі
та щоб скористатися найкращим із обох світів тут,
ви можете вибрати відповідний рівень для себе
насправді ми говоримо про b1 правильно
і подумайте про тему так, тему, яку
ми вивчаємо зараз, технології можна
знайти там,
подивіться, це те, що ви можете побачити,
це дуже легко встановити, це
абсолютно безкоштовно, скажіть, і
коли ви  чи є там, вам дуже
легко зробити це самостійно я вірю в
вас, і коли ви там, просто подумайте,
що це гарна ідея
попрактикувати словниковий запас, тему, яку ви
вивчали зараз, це технологія, і
це лише для вашого рівня  Тож давайте зустрінемося
тут у вікторині з вашим набором для підготовки до англійської мови,
тому що насправді це ваше домашнє завдання
спершу написати,
як UPS може допомогти вам у вивченні
мови та які програми ви використовуєте чи
хотіли б використовувати та бути  готовий поділитися
своїми причинами, чому ви пам’ятаєте, що це
означає, безумовно, саме сюди ви можете
надіслати свої записи, якщо вам потрібно
отримати мій відгук і якусь ціну, але
це ваше домашнє завдання, але це
не кінець нашого уроку, тому що  наступна
частина про бабусю. Давайте будемо свого
роду містком від тексту про програми
до граматики завдання, які ви будете
переглядати той самий текст ще раз, а
тепер завдання полягає в тому, щоб знайти речення в
пасивному стані, підрахувати, скільки речень
у пасивному  чи можете ви знайти там, зайняти
менше хвилини, зробіть це самостійно
двома реченнями:
перше – нові запитання, що додаються
щомісяця, пасивний загін додається до
дієслів дієслово to be в теперішньому часі є та дієприкметник минулого
додано правильно, а друге
– Clips aren  't downloaded with the
app aren't download it again дієслово to
be але в негативній формі не
завантажено, тому сьогодні наш другий
урок про пасивний залог, і сьогодні ми
зосередимося на активному або пасивному, як
перетворити активний  Перейти до пасивної готовності
чи знаєте ви, що сьогодні майже третина
з семи і восьми мільярдів
людей у світі регулярно використовують Інтернет, ак
ивний чи пасивний, як ви знаєте, як ск
зати відповідь, давайте проаналізуємо два ре
ення, які Олександр Грем Белл винайшов те
ефон і телефон  був винайдений
Олександром Грехемом Беллом, насправді більшість
речень приблизно однакова ідея
винахідник і винахід, але в
першому реченні перед дієсловом йде who
do where і після дієслова йде
об’єкт винахід, тоді як у другому
реченні перед дієсловом йде об’єкт
і винахід, а після дієслова goes a
doer,
то це означає, що якщо перед дієсловом
go doer of the action це активний залог,
давайте підсумуємо активним залогом,
спочатку підмет є doer van Gogh, дієслово,
а потім може бути активним об’єктом
голос, тоді як у пасивному задатку спочатку
йде об'єкт, цей об'єкт, який ви бачите,
потім дієслово, а останній може іти
виконавець, як перетворити активний у пасив,
давайте покриємо  етапи спочатку
визначимо дієслово, а потім об’єкт, який
йде після дієслова, що слід іти першим і
стає новим підметом nice,
потім ми повинні перетворити дієслово з активного
в пасивний, як зробити пасивний
залог формулою to be плюс причастник минулого
минулого часу  дієслово, яке у нас
було в активному праві, okay, а потім
зверніть увагу на тип
рядка could go a doer
чи завжди нам потрібен виконавець гарне запитання
давайте подивимося на кілька речень,
першим цей телефон молодий був виготовлений у
Китаї спочатку  активний або пасивний стан
утворюється так, як
дієслова - перший має бути, а
інший є причастем минулого часу, тому
формула і вона говорить, що це
пасивний залог, добре, перш ніж дієслово стане
новим підметом, але що було зроблено мені дійсно
цікаво знати  імена всіх
китайських робітників, які зробили цей телефон
, ми, звичайно, не
те, що нам важливіше
знати країну, де був виготовлений телефон,
тож коли інформація
про виконавця не дуже  важливо, звичайно,
ми можемо пропустити це добре, що ще
телефон було винайдено в 1876 році, а радіо
було винайдено 20 років потому, що
важливо в цьому реченні, хто винайшов
або коли, де ці інструменти винайшли,
безумовно, увага приділяється часу, а
не людині, яку ми не повинні  використовуйте виконавця
кожного разу, особливо коли ми не знаємо,
хто це зробив чи що це не важливо
для цього конкретного речення.
вісім мільярдів людей регулярно
користуються Інтернетом, що означають кольори,
як на схемі з лініями та
стрілками, праворуч це активний залог,
тому що дієслово вживає перед ним
Дьюар, хто дійсно використовує, а
після дієслова what
об’єкт давайте перетворимо його на пасивний що
перш за все, зараз Інтернет правильно,
це має йти спочатку, потім ми зосередимося
на дієслові та перетворимо його на пасив за
допомогою формули nice, а в самому кінці
після дієслова ми будемо pu  т хто, люди,
давайте перевіримо, який результат сьогодні
Інтернетом регулярно користується майже 1/3
із семи і восьми мільярдів
людей у
ті тадам, це результат, що нам вд
лося перетворити речення в активному го
осі на па
ивний.  Настав час підсумувати весь урок,
сьогодні ми говорили про програми для вивчення
мови, і дозвольте мені нагадати вам про домашнє
завдання, щоб відповісти на ці запитання
в письмовій формі та поділитися своїми
висновками, щоб поділитися з усіма нами
програмами, якими ви дійсно користуєтесь і які допомагають
ти покращиш свою англійську, готовий до
цього, ти чуєш дзвіночок, це означає,
що наш урок закінчено,
дякую за участь, слідкуйте за
оновленнями та до скорого побачення, до побачення
[Музика]